[Music]
my name's Dennis McCarthy and I've been
the pitcher car coordinator for the Fast
& Furious franchise now for over ten
years with every Fast & Furious film I
try to match the car to the character I
think their vehicles an extension of
their personality everybody has that one
perfect car the car that they dream of
driving what I try to do is get
everybody's car into the movie whether
it's a muscle car
classic inventory and European exotic
car you try to include everything we can
because everybody wants to get a paper
copy one thing that separates the Fast
and Furious franchise one of the movies
is a little level that we push these
vehicles how many other films would just
throw a perfectly good cars out of a
hair
you want to watch a movie where you're
seeing cars do amazing things like real
things then that's where forces come in
with a game that's as close to reality
as you can get the beauty of the war is
the Furious 7 cars they are an exact
replica of what we built through my shop
when I first had the opportunity to play
the game I realized my how these cars
handle just like the real thing and I've
spent a lot of time behind the wheel so
the Furious 7 cars and then the floor is
a game they nailed
not just the graphics and the clarity
but the way the cars react
- reacts the way the cars power slide
through the corner
when once where cars annoy the cast and
crew ever got behind the wheel love now
millions who get behind the wheel of a
furious 70s
[Music]
only on xbox